quant à l'équipe de france avant son
match de jeudi contre le danemark
qu'elle s'est remise à l'entraînement
après s'être fait à l'idée de jouer sans
inédit n'zi dan yann lavoix andré germa
vous avez adoré la chorale des petits
bleus vous avez apprécié ou tout du
moins remarqué qu'il chantait désormais
les paroles de la marseillaise
faut dire que la veille des matches il
s'entraîne
par dix voix
manger de tout
e
c'était le petit conservatoire de roger
lemerre ancien entraîneur de l'équipe de
france militaire
zidane suspendu dugarry blessés
deschamps petit blanc lizarazu sous la
menace d'un deuxième carton jaune
l'équipe de france qui jouera mercredi
sera donc amputée de nombreux titulaires
ça tombe bien les remplaçants un peu
lassé de jouer au tennis ballon sont
prêts elle a pas de différence entre
entre les joueurs qui ne jouent et qui
ne joue pas parce que bon on a un
collectif on est toujours ensemble ya
toujours une bonne ambiance et c'est ce
qui nous permet de nous sentir de vous
sentir tous ensemble pour s'aventurer
la bonne nouvelle c'est stéphane
guivarc'h qui est à nouveau opérationnel
il pourrait donc bien être
l'avant-centre des bleus face au
danemark mercredi
c'est ici au château de pizay que les
français sont arrivés en début de soirée
situé à 30 minutes de lyon au coeur du
beaujolais
les français seront ici les seuls à
occuper les lieux
choyé comme des paons en pâte
le patron et de lyon alors croyez le
bien la france ne vient pas en vacances
dans la région mon souci c'est d'aller
dans un rayon d'une région que je
connais bien puisque c'est la mienne
il ya un superbe stade il va y avoir je
dirais des couleurs il va y avoir de
l'ambiance
il faut que l'équipe de france soit
présente donc nous mettrons une très
bonne équipe tremblay danois et mais ces
gars seront là